we finally have a new Man of Steel yes
after news broke that David cornswept
will become the next Superman and Clark
Kent in Superman Legacy it's time to
take a deep dive into his life so who is
this guy who will help launch the new DC
Universe here are five things you need
to know
[Music]
at number five acting is in his genes
David's late Father John was a stage
actor before becoming a lawyer and David
first became interested in the craft
after seeing his sister perform in a
play he then follow in her footsteps by
doing his first play at the age of nine
at number four his grandfather created
the hugely successful children's book
series Choose Your Own Adventure yes
Edward Packard invented the genre called
interactive fiction after thinking up
some bedtime stories for his own kids
one of whom was David's mom at number
three David got his big break starring
in Ryan Murphy's 2019 series the
politician as the bisexual character
River Barkley maybe it was just where he
needed
a year later David starred in another
Murphy series Hollywood about the Golden
Age of Tinseltown David what is it like
being a good actor trying to play a
terrible actor did you just call me a
good actor
at number two he is aware he looks like
the last man to play Superman on the big
screen Henry Cavill
in his 2019 interview with Entertainment
Weekly David told the mag he's known for
years the two look alike it came to my
attention before the internet got a hold
of me
and that leads to number one it's been a
dream of his to Don the red cape yes in
that same ew article the actor revealed
My Pie in the Sky ambition is definitely
to play Superman
[Music]
but he saw himself doing a different
version
I love the Henry Cavill dark and gritty
take but I would love to see the next
one be very bright and optimistic so
let's see if he gets his wish
[Music]